47 countries have been removed from the
covid red list of countries for english
travelers now that leaves only seven
countries where the strict testing and
quarantine rules remain in place that
tweet coming from the transport
secretary grant shaps the announcement
uh made there in the last few minutes as
you can see on the screen there uh from
grant chaps on twitter now the countries
that are still on the red list are
colombia peru haiti and venezuela also
on the list still are the dominican
republic panama and ecuador
now grant shap's transport secretary
also saying that he was making changes
so that travelers visiting
england the uk will have fewer entry
requirements by recognizing those with
fully uh vaccinated status from 37
new uh countries and territories uh well
let's head straight to westminster and
our chief political correspondent uh i'm
sorry before we go to uh our chief
political correspondent we will just
hear what grant chaps has had to say
it's obviously a major step forward for
um travel and for people wanting to
travel and for the travel sector with 47
countries coming off the red list
meaning people can now travel amongst
other changes
we know with coronavirus
that some things can change but i do
also think that at this stage with so
many people fully vaccinated both here
at home but also now abroad but things
have settled down a lot and that's why
this is a major step forward today
by switching to lateral flow tests
you're removing the way the uk checks
for variants is that wise
one of the great things now with people
fully vaccinated from the uk uh is it's
much easier
to
allow people to travel and also to
accept 37 other countries whose tests we
all vaccinations we will now be
able to accept we will still want to
have that check-in of a lateral flow
test
but of course if that turns out to be
positive people will be able to
immediately take a pcr test and they'll
be able to do that through the nhs in
the normal way as well and so it will be
pretty quick and convenient and the good
thing with the lateral flow test is you
get your results straight away people
are very accustomed to them now and that
should help